I'm Speaker of the House Newt Gingrich
calling out these schizophrenic insanity
surrounding the treatment of President
Trump joining us now with more reaction
from Judicial Watch tom Fitton
and Fox News contributor Sarah Carter
said you know an on story about a
non-event I think that that pretty much
sums up the media hysteria yesterday but
what they missed yesterday was what you
were reporting and we were reporting and
that is just how abusively biased struck
and Paige were and how many people were
in the loop knowing that the fix was in
as it relates to doing a real
investigation into Hillary Clinton
before they interviewed her exonerations
before any investigation so you know
that's got to be frustrating as you have
been unpeeling every layer of this onion
well it's very frustrating Sean because
what we see is leaks come out so as
information comes out about the FBI
about these text messages between these
two FBI agents Peter struck and Lisa
page and as more evidence starts to
unravel you get a leak like this that
goes to the New York Times and it's
really an on story because the president
has every right to question whether or
not you know Special Counsel Moeller is
is right for this job he has every right
to discuss this privately with his
attorneys and as we see nothing happened
so he didn't fire special counsel
Moeller he talked with someone about the
circumstances apparently around Special
Counsel Moeller so there was no order to
actually fire him and I think what's
really frustrating is that the American
people are not getting well informed by
all of these very important news
agencies I mean the New York Times The
Washington Post CNN MSNBC they're not
focused on these stories and right now
what we know is that the FBI and let's
go back to the story we just talked
about the other day Sean the fact that
the FBI and the DOJ said we lost all of
these five months of text messages
through a technical glitch and you won't
be able to get them and then all of the
sudden now they have them we have to ask
why did they say that to begin with what
are they hiding what is going on it's
job watchdogs why didn't rot Rosenstein
just hours before the house Intel
committee was was going to get the
subpoenaed documents was he begging Paul
Ryan please please don't release this
tom Fitton one of the roles that
Judicial Watch has plated I think has
been very key in getting information I
know you file a lot of Freedom of
Information Act requests but think about
this all right so I think we're I hope
it looks like we'll get the memo next
week probably mid week after the State
of the Union but why do we have to wait
to get the 50,000 text messages why not
release them all right they whatever
right maybe to look for information that
could put somebody in harm's way fair
enough what that doesn't take that long
that's exactly right we've been asking
for we have numerous requests to which
these text messages are probably
responsive and lawsuits and we've been
getting the runaround we've been asking
about them since we found out about it
we asked the Justice Department and FBI
what's going on here and they basically
told us if you want them sue us again
and you know we did sue them we asked
for the text messages we sued and a few
hours later they found them this is
about you know this news story that was
planted this week about the president
Trump's concerns about Moeller the text
messages the gamesmanship there the
Justice Department fighting the the
House on releasing a summary memo of
this underlying material it's all about
protecting the Moller operation and what
I think the headline is in the New York
Times Washington Post is Muller has
conflicts that have been unaddressed he
for instance is investigating the firing
of Comey the very job opening for which
he interviewed why is he why is he
anywhere near this investigation given
that conflict and why is the president
the one having to raise it where's the
Justice Department rod Rosen's a Des
Moines and making sure that Melinda gun
conflict-free the daily B's to say it
Rosenstein and call me and McCabe we're
all in this memo we'll see you next week
that's the one leak we got on it all
right yeah sorry you don't discussed
next week's of big news week even the
memo is only a small portion of what's
coming out in this case you know where I
know you are in the
- big investigative reports that I think
you'll be breaking next week one about
Andrew Weissman if I'm allowed to tip
your hand for you you did being the nice
guy that I am what's coming next week
and how big do you think this memo ends
up being well first it is true I think
you know we need to focus on the members
of the special council and Andrew
Weitzman sean has come up over and over
again and he's very important because
he's a central part of the investigation
so I do have something coming out next
week with regard to Andrew Weissman
another another very important facet
another story that's going to be out
next week is of course the FISA memo and
we expect that to be out sometime after
the State of the Union in midweek and
it's explosive and I know this not just
from talking to congressional members
but other law enforcement officials who
have gone to Congress as whistleblowers
about FISA abuse cases this should shock
every American and this is a way to keep
our country in check and you're right
it's one part of so many more pieces of
this puzzle because remember a lot of
this information j'onn is classified
it's just it's classified information so
we can't get our hands on it so they'll
go ahead and put out the pieces redacted
I think after the FISA memo sure real
quick Tom I got a roll Andrew Weissman
the number two at the moas Operations
sent an email supporting Sally aides his
attack on Trump's order refusal to
follow it went to Hillary Clinton's
election night party
why is he anywhere near this and a
leaked information about Paul Manafort
before he started investigating Paul
Manafort to the AP so many conflicts
with all of them it's all beginning to
come together next week will be a
massive news week on top of the State of
the Union and the memo being really